foreign
s against a government they say is
becoming less democratic
[Applause]
the accused of jailing opponents
silencing Independent Media and being
influenced by Russia
protesters in thibilisi are calling for
the release of jail ex president Mikhail
sakaswili the two-term leader is serving
six years in prison for abuse of power
in 89 we were fighting pro-ration
communist government here on the streets
of trilisi exactly the same way today we
are fighting pro-putinist government in
Georgia
Georgia applied for EU membership along
with Ukraine and Moldova days after
Russia invaded Ukraine last year in June
the EU called on Tbilisi for political
and judicial changes to gain membership
open and say recent government actions
harmed Georgia's chances 32 years ago
Georgia got the independence from Soviet
Union and that is why we stand here
because
and like for us the most important is
and father steps is to go to new
membership and NATO membership and
Georgian people are united around this
goal
last month widespread protests forced
the government to abandon a
controversial bill
it would have required any
non-governmental agency receiving money
from abroad to register as a foreign
agent
critics say the bill was modeled on one
introduced in Russia years earlier to
suppress dissent
sadly the government controlled by the
criminals trying to turn our country
into a Russian Province so the people
who gathered here today demand the
European future of our country we won't
get tired in this fight
says it remains committed to Georgia's
EU
but leaders have stepped up anti-western
rhetoric after the U.S ban visas for
four judges facing corruption
accusations Washington's toughening of
stance towards an ally comes after
concerns about Georgia's shift towards
Russia
um Sharif al-jazeera